[Music]
what did you miss them all I miss I miss
going to school playing on playgrounds
playing with my friends the most and I
miss about my school is the food vendor
because I like the rice the beans the
egg and because I have no money but the
egg they don't know tangi changing
current in him near butcher savoy and
Quarantine I miss school and my
classmates they laughed and my friends
and I miss the gossip in the school
corridor and disturbing lesson 3 woof
Roca what I miss most in school is my
math class because I don't really
understand the unlights itchin they do
not explain well and some of us we don't
we don't understand they were they right
one day when the whiteboard there are
hundreds means are rough this is DW is
covered nineteen special I'm Kate
Ferguson thanks for joining me
the coronavirus has upended the lives of
hundreds of millions of children around
the world in many countries kids have
been cooped up at home for weeks forcing
parents to become educators while
working their regular jobs now as
restrictions begin to be lifted for some
kids here in Europe it's back to school
but what can they expect when they
return this next report takes us to
Norway and Denmark in Norway just going
to school looks like you're on vacation
that's the way it was before the
coronavirus crisis hit and the way it
still is now Osmond has been bringing
his two boys and brick and Lorenz to the
bus stop every morning for the past four
weeks the strictest hygiene rules apply
inside the school bus but things will
look different at school today for the
time being they're keeping separate
areas for each class we have a larger
area over there and the other class can
meet behind the playground
good hygiene practices have always been
compulsory in Norwegian schools what's
new is that the minimum distance of 1
meter is no longer needed even though
there's plenty of space between the
tables in M bricks classroom but for the
teacher Lena Hagin said one thing is
much more important the teachers can
finally hold the children in their arms
again and comfort them when they've
fallen down for example it hasn't been
possible for a while it's very unnatural
if you have to put on a mask every time
do it so far Norway has had only
positive experiences with its school
openings Norwegian epidemiologists have
discovered that children hardly infect
each other they feel that the school
opening confirms their findings
you know advice was not to close the
schools at that time it was a political
decision in a very confusing situation
now the Norwegian government is unsure
that the school closings were even
necessary
a few hundred kilometers to the south is
Copenhagen Denmark like the Norwegians
the Danes also follow very strict
coronavirus guidelines they were the
first Scandinavian country to close the
borders shops and schools but
kindergartens and primary schools
reopened in mid-april and in a funny way
to the Tivoli amusement park in the
middle of Copenhagen let daycare groups
into the empty park free of charge
teachers go outside with their students
as often as possible the infection rate
remains low despite open schools one of
the great critics of the school openings
Alan Ron drove a violinist at the
University of Copenhagen has changed his
mind over time to do some job
recruitment there were many who like me
were worried about the schools reopening
in school and all the data so far has
shown us that these concerns were
unfounded at the Haiku point the
experience we've had in Denmark is the
best argument for the school's reopening
man got cooled in the school on back in
Norway kids are gearing up for the
summer break in places it will look like
this scene with M brick and his
classmates the view that learning
playing or even swimming children hardly
play a role in the transmission of the
coronavirus has become more and more
accepted at least in Scandinavia for
more on the reopening of schools I'm
joined there by posi Sal Berg professor
of education policy at the Gonski
Institute at the University of New South
Wales in Sydney Australia
professor Sal Berg welcome to the
program you've described this time as
the biggest educational experiment in
history what did you mean by that well
never before in the history we have had
almost all the schools in the world
closed for several weeks we had about
1.5 billion children learning from home
when their classes and schools were
closed so this is one part of the
experiment then the other one is that
our school systems around the world have
never experienced such a kind of a rapid
shift in the core way of working that is
a classroom based teaching into online
learning and these two two areas two
parts of the experiment makes it
interesting you've written that kids
returning to school may need more breaks
more time to play than they had before
why do you say this well one thing is
that the the the time for children to
play have time for themselves during the
school and the school days around the
world has really reduced during the last
20 years and now is the time when the
children are returning to school to
reconnect the the resources back to
their friends after the several weeks of
being home through their parents the
other thing is simple a medical reason
all the pediatricians and medical
experts are saying that the this type of
lockdown our social distancing that the
two
have when they have been staying away
from schools and with their families can
be emotionally very demanding for
children and there's nothing better to
to do to help kids when they're in
school then keeping more time to be with
their friends and talk about how they
feel and what's going on with their
lives
there's also been a lot of talk about
the digital divide children have
experienced during lockdown
tell me about what that means well you
know the interesting thing is that
already before the rakovict Crisis
Center August walk down and look down
some and school courses we knew that
although most most families and what
most people were connected to the
Internet but we knew that there were
some issues and some places where that
was not possible now we do do know this
much better what they what this pandemic
has really revealed around the world is
that that we cannot really rely on the
fact that the internet connection and
access to the internet would mean that
the children for example would have a
reliable connection to all these
services and things that they would need
from their schools in many places the
vast majority of children have not had a
proper connection to those platforms and
teaching that the schools are provided
the other thing is that the school they
have their number of schools actually
only two thirds of the schools in the
OECD countries report that they have
facilities and normal within the school
to properly provide online teaching to
the children at home so so these things
together really create this divide I
think we understand must have a pandemic
and before professor salver 'ok thank
you so much for your time time now to
answer your questions about kovat 19
over to our science correspondent
derrick williams
if you live in a country where there are
no active cases of kovat 19 and the
borders are closed is it still necessary
to wear a mask after 14 days the debate
on whether or not to wear a mask and
when has been going on for months and
I'm certainly not going to solve it
definitively here when the w-h-o took so
long to make up its mind that it's a
good idea but but no one denies that if
they aren't worn properly and washed or
disposed of regularly masks can
potentially do more harm than good so so
health care authorities all over the
world will be taking that into account
as they tighten or loosen restrictions
on on wearing them in the situation you
described no active cases in the country
for 14 days and closed borders I
personally would hope and expect that I
could leave my mask at home but but then
maybe I'm biased I mean I really hate
wearing them if you contract covin 19
but don't succumb to it can the virus
still cause damage that can build up and
harm you down the line we'll only find
this out in the coming months and years
as as any possible creeping physical
effects make themselves known but but
the expectation is that most of those
who have no symptoms or relatively mild
symptoms of the disease will will
recover as fully as they would from any
other respiratory sickness however
there's no question that people who have
severe cases of Kovan 19 like like those
who have to be intubated and ventilated
that they can end up with serious damage
to their lungs that will remain with
them for the rest of their lives the
same goes for patients whose kidneys are
affected or those were those who have
embolisms or strokes caused by blood
clotting
if they're not sure about immunity due
to antibodies and patients who have
recovered then what's the difference
with vaccine induced antibodies how the
body responds to an infection with a
pathogen is complex and it involves more
than just producing antibodies for
example what are known as t-cells also
play a big role in immune response and
in future immunity we still don't know
exactly how it all works with kovat 19
but what we do know from from other
diseases is that immunity can be
influenced by how badly you had the
disease if that holds true for kovat 19
as well then people who had mild cases
might later not be as immune to
reinfection as someone who had a bad
case so so one thing vaccine developers
are trying to do is mimic the strong
immune system response caused by a bad
infection
but but obviously without the symptoms
that led to it
the goal is to induce immunity with a
vaccine that would be even better and
lasts even longer than if you had a
severe case of the disease
[Music]